Film Courage: Why do writers get stuck?
Alan Watt, Author, Screenwriter and Founder
of L.A. Writers' Lab: Why do writers get stuck?
Well, you want to have a good outline.
Writers gets stuck sometime because they come
up with a great idea and they immediately
tart writing the idea which is fine but at
some point you are going to want to stop and
do some kind of outline.
And here is the thing.
This is where writers go “Yeah but I heard
that Woody Allen never outlined.
Charlie Kaufman never outlines.”
And the truth is they do, they probably just
done write their outline down.
They have been writing stories for such a
long time and they probably do have lots of
notes and they have probably developed such
a…story structure becomes second nature
to them.
They’ve become masters and so they are naturally
connected to this process.
But I would think the main reason writers
get stuck is they are not working off of some
kind of an outline.
It could be the most rudimentary outline but
you’ve got to have something to work from.
Or the irony is if you don’t have an outline
you are actually going to lose confidence
when you get to a point where you start to
feel stuck.
Because you are always going to get stuck
at some point in the process but if you’ve
got some point of basic sense of the story
structure, basic sense of the movement you
can actually get excited about the point that
you get stuck because you know where the story
is going to go and that’s where you can
kind of relax into the panic and let your
characters speak to you and go in directions
that you never imagined that are actually
going to support where the story wants to
go.
That’s why I always say if you know you’re
going to go left, go right.
So if I know this is going to happen, let
me explore the opposite and relax in the fact
that I’m going to get to where I’m going
it’s just that I’m not going to arrive
there the same way I thought I was going to.
Film Courage: I’m thinking of like THE FIRM
with Tom Cruise…well I don’t want to give
any spoilers away.
Alan: I don’t think you are giving any spoilers
away to a 30 year movie.
If you haven’t watched THE FIRM yet?
Film Courage: Okay…so I’m just thinking
of the living room scene where he comes back
and the partners are there and maybe I’m
forgetting this part?
Alan: Yes!
And totally different…this is where Robert
Towne…I love this!
Robert Towne adapted THE FIRM and he…I always
thought it was a great novel except the ending
felt like a total cheat because Mitch McDeere
ends up on a sailboat with 10 million dollars
and he’s in like the Cayman Islands or something
and he’s not a lawyer any more but he wanted
to be a lawyer.
He loved being a lawyer.
And so Robert Towne he read it and said “Wait
a minute?
Why can’t he be a lawyer at the end of the
story?
But have a transformation?”
So in the living room scene (it’s been decades
since I’ve seen this movie).
But in the living room scene is where he confronts
is it the mobsters and the people from his
law firm?
Film Courage: Maybe…and isn’t is wife
there?
Alan: But what he basically does is he says
“I’m a lawyer and I work for you but I
also have all of your stuff and if anything
happens to me you guys are messed up.”
And so that’s what John Grisham didn’t
do.
But that’s what makes Robert Towne a genius
is because he understands story structure,
he understands transformation.
I mean Josh Grisham is brilliant, I love John
Grisham.
But the ending of that felt like a cop-out
to me because he just goes of…that ending
is almost a tragedy.
He’s going to spend the rest of his life
in hiding (in the novel) in hiding in the
Cayman Islands with 10 million dollars.
That sounds like a nightmare!
Who wants that life because he’s in hiding?
But the way Robert Towne did it was masterful
because he was true to the dramatic question
about a guy who was an idealistic lawyer who
takes a job for a “dirty firm” and ends
up in a horror show and he manages a way to
climb out and outsmart the villains.
Brilliant!